les producteurs se préparent à la
légalisation et en auront pour tous les
goûts toute une gamme de produits est
prête à être mise en marché du plus
faible au plus puissant
c'est comme si vous aviez le choix entre
acheter ma bière du vin ou de la vodka
certaines variétés de cannabis séchées
pour ea d'être une concentration de thc
frôlant les 30%
c'est beaucoup plus que la marijuana des
années 80 où le taux était en moyenne de
3%
d'ailleurs le thc éléments
principalement psycho actifs dans le
cannabis qui cause un effet euphorisant
des experts auraient voulu qu'ottawa
limite la puissance des produits séchés
pour les acheteurs de 18 à 25 ans pour
ne pas nuire au développement du cerveau
d'autres suggérait de taxer le cannabis
en fonction de sa puissance mais le
gouvernement trudeau n'a pas retenu ses
propositions